The question is, should you keep adding content and how often should you keep adding content?
We are not Google so we can't give you like a specific answer on what is, you know, the
perfect thing that you can do when you are building your website and when it comes down
to content.
But we can tell you what we are doing that has been working for us.
So usually if this is the first website that you are building, you put on the content,
you are doing all the on-pages here, you are setting this up, don't touch it for a couple
of months and then in a couple of months, two, three, four months, do the ranking, see
how your website is doing and then you can add content.
But I would not keep editing, I would not keep touching, just let it do its course,
keep getting other deals, focus on other things and just kind of focus on other things, don't
keep adding or editing because Google is crawling your website, is ranking your website
and so you don't want to mess too much with it.
So I would say wait a couple of months, do the rankings after that, see how your website
is doing.
If it's not doing great, if it's still on page five, six, seven and you are not seeing
it, you know, getting better, then add some content.
And I would start with adding 500 words per page every week.
Do that and then after a month, do the rankings again and see if, and I mean, it doesn't have
to be page one, number one, but it should be progressively getting better.
And again, it's not just about content, you are also going to have to do other things
to rank it if it's not ranking, but content will be something major for your website and
so that's something that you want to do.
You want to be checking it and adding if needed.
If your website is ranking, do not touch it.
That is one of the main rules that we have.
If your website is on page one and it's ranking really well, it's getting leads.
Don't think, oh, well, what can it, how much more better it could be doing if I added more
content, if I touch it up or well, it's kind of ugly.
I don't really like the content I'm going to edit.
Don't touch it.
If it's ranking, if it's producing, don't touch it.
Just leave it because it's working.
It has been working and there's no need for you to touch it or mess with it.
So leave it.
You only go on and add content, edit content if it's not ranking or producing.
And that's it for content.